comme on sait que les scènes intimes
sont toujours un peu gênante voilà on y
est on a là tous tournés ici même
isabelle est ce que la scène était aussi
drôle la tournée qu'elle l'ait
réellement dans le film la scène
franchement la scène d'amour est folle
charlie et dit seulement vos amis
c'était moi encore sarouel
je sais pas c'est ok en régie à deux
traducteurs ils sont servis de minutes
ils vont se [ __ ] sur la gueule
retentissant qui parfaitement
c'était aussi drôle aka film et à
regarder le pas du tout c'est drôle que
moi trop de tort ouais c'est ça le
traducteur il traduit des vannes en fait
elle te vendre le produit
[Musique]
parce que nos gars le gall se défonce
tout seul il est bas quoi il traduit le
mec il va nous bat l'insulté va traduire
le fait qu'ils se refilent des experts
expliquent que la ministre charlize
theron manque d'humour et sur le
tournage service l es l et es lédar cas
où elle ira sera et paraît qu'elle était
très drôle sur le tournage de charlize
et ça veut dire est ce qu'elle vous
était détendue parce que dans le film ou
jouer un rôle vous êtes plutôt sérieuse
parce que pour nous c'était réellement
très important pour ce monde et
peut-être que j'aurais pu effectivement
quelqu'un qui se présenteraient à la
présidence était candidate et je pense
que cette histoire d'amour est également
le film je pense qu'elle était plutôt
drôle je ne pense pas que ce soit
quelqu'un d'aussi sérieux et je pense
que c'est qu'un personnage gala d'humour
inhabituel qu'il se prend pas trop au
sérieux et je pense que ferait également
confiant quant aux chances lorsqu'ils
sont ensemble
elle exagère peut-être un petit peu les
choses alors c'est une mise en lambeaux
du temps mais ça
les descendants des princes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
jeremic
on va faire venir les 37 eur 9 juillet
jeudi ils vont venir on va les voir de
visu et peut-être que là il va envoyer
c'est une des questions posées une
question qu'est ce que vous vous devez
dire ce que vous avez envie de dire à
notre public français pour qu'ils
aillent voir le film nous on a adoré le
film franchement est excellent on est
franchement on est pris dedans du début
à la fin
valérie benaïm je sais qui d'autre l'a
vu parce que vous tourner la vie in the
first time that every body now i'm so
ils arrivent ils arrivent pas oui merci
pourquoi ils veulent oser ils veulent de
l'argent
abdou goth monnaie elle va parler du
combat
d'accord mais dites-moi rondelle il
arrive comme ça vous allez répondre
ils vont faire la france ne l'a tout de
suite les chéris d'ailleurs on va on va
amener des transferts dans un instant
est-ce que vous restez avec nous encore
une dizaine de minutes je vous explique
charlie day 1a les voilà ouais c'est pas
du tout le même délire
sanaa
voilà chers du terral et sa femme
[Applaudissements]
alors à 19,6 parce que comme on est et
on est un petit peu en retard
est ce que vous pouvez dire à 7 et à
charlize que je dois envoyer la pub
parce que ailleurs je dois faire rentrer
un petit peu d'argent mais il faut le
dire un peu
vraiment on est dans la barre car on est
dans la barca voulez vous mettre
derrière sam
alors mettez vous dit rien mettez-vous
mais on aimerait que les gens qu'on peut
parler pour le public aux filles parce
que je ne vois pas c'est quand même pas
non nadia alors dit elle est franchement
[Rires]
ça dope vous êtes vous êtes un petit peu
et moustiers s'est mis à bien alors on
annule cette question parce qu'après ils
doivent partir donc on va leur poser une
dernière question est ce que monsieur
est ce que vous avez un message à faire
passer au public français pour qu'ils
aillent voir le film dans le micro
nadière dans le micro
[Musique]
oui d'autant qu'il sortait de chez vous
ça va vous plaire
on préfère pas votre maman quand même
franchement je pense qu ils ont été très
bons les douze travaux alors dans le
film aussi y'a un truc il a une autre
traduction affaires en fait là